in our morning round health officials
are urging all Americans over six months
old to get a flu shot now takes about
two weeks for the maximum protection to
develop flu activity is expected to
picked up by next month
last season nearly 80,000 Americans died
from the virus that's the highest number
since modern tracking began and the CDC
director told CBS this morning that
concerns about a flu pandemic keep him
up at night our dr. Jon LaPook is making
a house call in our green room it's a
very plush nice house yes they give nora
and maybe gale god beyond and i already
got ours good morning doctor good
morning nice to be able to make a house
call why our vaccine why is this so
important
oh this is crucially important I mean
last year almost 80,000 people died from
the flu and many kids of so many kids
died and most of them did not get the
flu vaccine how effective is it you know
it varies from year to year I mean
sometimes it's 25% sometimes a little
more sometimes it could be as high as 50
60 percent but the point is that it's
better than nothing and even if you go
on and get the flu it sometimes is able
to attenuate to weaken the amount of flu
that you get so even though you get the
flu you don't get a sick struggle with
John because most of the times I don't
get the flu shot I've gotten it last
year because Nora beat me to death about
it and actually then I got it one year
because it was the only way I could go
see Robin Roberts in the hospital when
she was very ill right so I never ever
get it and I don't get the flu and I'm
really terrified of needles so why
should somebody like me get it if they
go all these years and they never get
sick I know it sounds like a very
ignorant question no no it's it's a
great question let's go back to why
you're afraid of needles because I'll
make a confession on national television
when I go to get the flu shot I have a
little bit of fear too and it dates back
to when I was a kid yeah yeah and the
doctor was chasing me around the table
okay I haven't had a flu shot hurt me in
50 years but that memory the silhouette
it still resonates with I'm gonna let
you prep and give me that you know all
right so as we talk first of all we've
talked beforehand and I've gotten your
medical history I have thoroughly washed
my hands before hand and now just to
make a little extra I'm gonna get the
Purell here and
put the gloves although the CDC said
that they don't always use gloves but
what the heck yeah - pro gloves here
apropos PG John just got his shots right
LeAnn and the CDC it was she was like
the Babe Ruth of nurses anyway she gave
the shot and because she'd done so many
and successfully and it was I didn't
even feel it
the Babe Ruth of all right ready you
having a good morning and that's it all
done you want to fold that see you
through you hold that and and what's
very close with this little safety cap
so we used to stick our selves and we
would do it and that's it and we get a
CBS this morning band-aid how great is
that although it's sticking to my glove
there's no pressure I mean the nope near
no peer pressure there is peer pressure
and I do want to say that because you
we're good thank you very much and I
mean I think it's great for people to
see it's really not a big deal but I do
understand Gail I totally understand the
reluctance and you know what you don't
to do that in front of millions of
people on national television you know
we'll we'll go ahead and talk about
doing it any privacy Evan you're not
gonna be chasing her around the table
like here no no no thank you for this
opportunity to do this better lollipop